hello there I am altar Bernays yak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors reach for the sky
because today we're talking about the
best of everyone's favourite deputy Tom
Hanks Tom Hanks has had one hell of a
career the two-time Oscar winner and
five-time nominee has been a constant
presence in Hollywood since the early
eighties at 60 years old he's still
leading films a few times a year and his
newest effort solely directed by Clint
Eastwood hit theaters this past weekend
so let's give thanks for Hanks yeah
number five
Captain John Miller in Saving Private
Ryan Tom makes rarely makes a bad movie
and is always a welcomed personality to
see up on the big screen so choosing
just five performances from him was no
easy task
Saving Private Ryan was revolutionary
for many reasons but without Hanks as
Captain Miller I don't think it would
have quite reached the legendary status
it has today when his three brothers are
all killed in combat world war two
soldier James Ryan is supposed to be
sent home to the States finding him
however is another story
Captain John Miller and a small group of
his finest men are tasked with the
mission to bring the young Ryan home but
that's easier said than done in the
middle of war-torn Europe Hanks is our
guide from the beginning of the film the
iconic Normandy battle sequence is
mostly from his perspective and in the
middle of the madness he shows us a
combination of courage and fear that
sets the tone for the rest of the movie
he isn't the only great performance here
but I believe his is the most impressive
because of the many hats captain Miller
is forced to wear throughout the film in
front of his men he is almost always
absolute in his commands and even has a
sense of humor about his authority at
times the best scenes come when that
wall is taken down and we see the real
man behind the uniform he can be funny
rimmel rimmel the baby sit a bridge
that's the last I say in heaven brother
great thanks
thank you right thank retreatin thank
you he can be a mentor I can't see my
brothers faces I want to think of home I
think of some specific I think of my my
hammock in the backyard
my wife pruning the rose bushes and a
pair of my old work gloves but most
importantly we can see him at his most
vulnerable my favorite scene in this
features captain Miller trying to
explain how he lives
with giving commands that can get his
men killed we end up killing one of your
man you telling yourself
it happened so you could save the lives
of two or three or ten others so you
rationalize making the choice of course
directed by Steven Spielberg Saving
Private Ryan is a classic film with
Hanks going above and beyond to prove
once again just how great he can be
number four Mike Sullivan in road to
perdition we're discussing the best
performances of Tom Hanks this one is
often overlooked it's a departure for
him in many ways and it features
basically none of his trademark humor
also a bit of a forgotten film but it
absolutely deserves to be recognized
Mike Sullivan is the stone cold yet
honorable enforcer of Midwestern crime
boss John Rooney when Mike's eldest son
sees his father involved in a botched
mob killing Rooney's organization led by
his son Connor turns against its
greatest ally this leads to Mike and his
son going on the run from the mob while
discovering a father-son bond that had
previously not existed based on a comic
book this is a darker role that Hanks
filled well who knew he could be such a
believable badass he shines in the
violent intense scenes will also
authentically conveying a strained
father-son relationship a relationship
that is the heartbeat of the film he
also plays down a lot of his usual
charisma for a stoic yet interesting man
hell-bent on revenge while
simultaneously trying to keep his son
from making the same mistakes he did
along with Tyler hoechlin who plays
Hanks his son and was just cast as
Superman in the Supergirl TV show Paul
Newman Jude Law Stanley Tucci and a pre
James Bond Daniel Craig round out a
great main cast that have some good
chemistry resulting in some fantastic
scenes director Sam Mendes creates a
visually stunning
piece with a pitch-perfect tone that
succeeds in every way it attempts the
rain seen the movie is worth watching
alone just for this scene it's
incredible I can make this whole video
just about Road to Perdition it's a film
that doesn't get the recognition it
deserves and Hanks is a big reason why
it's so good go check this one out
number three Josh Baskin in big I have a
soft spot for this movie I remember it
from when I was a kid and looking at it
now I can see just how brilliant Hanks
really was playing a 12 year old in a 30
year olds body after being embarrassed
at a local carnival for being too short
to ride 12 year old Josh Baskin makes a
wish to be big on a creepy
fortune-telling machine called Zoltar
the next day Josh wakes up as a 30 year
old man with the help of his best friend
Billy Josh manages to get a job in the
city his own apartment and even an adult
girlfriend Josh must navigate the
challenges of adulthood while trying to
find the Zoltar machine that was the
genesis of his metamorphosis from the
first moment we see him Hanks is
undeniably believable as a 12 and later
13 year old from the innocence in his
face to the nervous habits of a preteen
Hank's really embodies the spirit of a
kid that age I'd say it's his most
enjoyable performance delightful is not
a word I often use but it applies here
the movie n Hanks as Baskin are just
that delightful the famous piano scene
encapsulate s' the joyfulness of this
film perfectly how he interacts with the
other adults throughout the movie is
always fun to watch his effect on them
is always entertaining side note the
Zoltar machine is legit creepy the
mystery surrounding it is aided by a
great design and interesting visuals
that create a sense of flight and Wonder
great job by director and my favorite
Laverne Penny Marshall for almost any
other actor big would probably be the
performance of a career we're talking
about Tom Hanks here folks
onward and upward number two Forrest
Gump in Forrest Gump don't worry I'm not
going to do a Forrest Gump impression
I guess slow waited but lovable and
always positive Forrest Gump is the
inspiring story of a man who lives life
to the fullest
whether he's falling into historical
events playing ping pong or just running
Forrest can always make the best
of a bad situation however the love of
his life Jenny takes a more troubled
road on her journey as she crosses paths
with forest when she least expects it
the two have a special relationship that
is chronicled from childhood to
adulthood a lot of what worked for
hangsen big works here as well just in a
different way his childlike optimism is
still front and center this time however
it created a cultural phenomenon I can
recall kids yelling run Forrest run all
the time back when this came out it's a
performance that people really connected
to and hanks has the gold to show for it
this movie shows a ton of bad stuff
happening allusions to child abuse
friends and loved ones dying the horrors
of war and more but it's shown through
the eyes of an innocent man
it's shown through the eyes of someone
who against all odds takes it in stride
and makes the best possible life for
himself
that's probably why people liked this
character so much I'll admit I didn't
grow up with Forrest Gump I didn't see
the movie to later on so I don't quite
have the connection to him that others
do however I can see why he's such an
inspirational character also he loves Dr
Pepper a man after my own heart how can
I not like his incorrupt ability shows
itself in a few amazing scenes why don't
you love me Jenny
is is he smart he's very smart he's one
of the smartest in his class
it's an honest performance and feel
sincere the movies third act is where
most of those moments are and they work
great Hanks along with Robert Zemeckis
Eric Roth Alan Silvestri and more
created an everlasting character never
stopped running for us I can't stress
how difficult it was to only choose five
great Tom Hanks performances his career
is full of them so before we get to
number one let's take a look at some
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Tom Hanks
performance is Chuck Noland in castaway
I need to clear this up right now this
is not my favorite Tom Hanks performance
I don't think it's his most enjoyable or
the most fun to watch but what this guy
went through to make this movie carrying
an entire feature film by himself how he
made us care about a volleyball he gave
all of himself to make this character
happen there is no way I could have
ranked this performance below the top
spot FedEx Executive Chuck Nolan leads a
busy life often putting work in front of
family when his plane crashes into the
ocean and he narrowly survives he washes
ashore
on an uncharted uninhabited island with
nothing but a few FedEx packages a
volleyball named Wilson and his will to
survive no one holds on to hope that one
day he may return home to see his
fiancee Heather and regain the love that
was ripped away from him Hanks gained 50
pounds to play Nolan at the beginning of
the movie they shot all those scenes
then took a full year off from filming
in the time in-between Robert Zemeckis
made a whole other movie when they
resumed filming a year later Hanks had
dropped all the weight and then some
grew his hair out and looked like a
completely different person now all of
this could have been for nothing
just because you lose and gain weight
doesn't mean you'll give a great
performance but he does Hank is on
screen by himself for most of the movie
and while yes it does drag a little bit
at a few points for the most part he
makes the movie interesting his
interactions with the environment and
just learning to survive makes for a
really unique and engaging film
experience and who wasn't yelling well
sad after this movie was over he was
having believable conversations with an
inanimate object we might just make it
did that
she brain wolf regardless I would rather
take my chance out there in the ocean
than to stay here and die on the
shithole Island spending rest of my life
talking do I god damn I wanted to
mention that the plane crash scene is
actually terrified it's seemingly very
realistic and there is some impressive
effects work done in there too Hank's
had to go through a lot in that sequence
as well the movie tugs at your
heartstrings and doesn't stop through
the very end the island stuff is the
biggest part of course but it's
conversations back at home are also very
compelling Tom Hanks is a master there's
nothing else I can say the guy is
amazing if you want his best performance
go ahead and check out castaway if you
want his best movie in my opinion maybe
you should watch Road to Perdition or
big for fun Tom Hanks you can also check
out Forrest Gump or Saving Private Ryan
you see my problem here I want to hear
what you guys think what is your
favorite Tom Hanks movie and/or
performance who you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and come back next
week when we count down the top 5 worst
no no
hey we're we're not still doing that are
we we are ah okay well this is going to
be difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
you